what's going on guys Oscar nominations
around and no I'm not here to rant about
the snub of the lego movie I'm here to
talk about the nominees before they were
vying for Hollywood's top prize and
humble beginnings just like anybody else
and today we're gonna take a look at
them and people they were famous
Oscar vision let's kick it off with the
American sniper himself Bradley Cooper
now before he was sniping fools he was a
student at the new school where he was
in one of his very first TV appearances
asking a question to Sean Penn on Inside
the Actors Studio
hey mr. Penn my name is Bradley Cooper
I'm a second year actor my questions
regarding hurly-burly what was it like
to revisit a character Eddie after a
10-year hiatus did you have new
discoveries hey let's all play a little
game let's pretend that he's not
nominated for American sniper and that
he's nominated for Rocket Raccoon
instead how awesome would that be
America's Sweetheart Reese Witherspoon
is nominated for her performance in wild
but way back when she was in a TV movie
called desperate choices to save my
child so how long before we hear from
this doctor anyway I said the doctors
said that we have a finder
leukemia am I gonna die no but the
doctor wants you to start treatment
right away and that means that you'll
have to go into the hospital now for
just a little while something wrong see
me Kashi now all right let me get this
straight she was a female football
player with leukemia guys one of those
things is enough JK Simmons is nominated
for his badass performance in whiplash
you probably know him as Jay jonah
Jameson from spider-man or from his
performance in Oz but kids from the 90s
know him as barber Dan and the
Adventures of Pete and Pete I hear those
Krebbs star nightwalkers are pretty good
are you looking for razor sharp pivots
pinpoint stops increased trajectory well
who isn't
Knight walks oh yeah Wow things were
going great until barber Dan threw that
barber chair at big Pete's head thanks
speaking of folks who used to be in
spider-man movies Emma Stone is
nominated for Birdman now before she was
Oscar nominee Emma Stone she was little
Emily stone contestant on the reality
show in search of the Partridge Family
I'm sorry that's a grown-up song Emily
grounded
well benedict cumberbatch was bound to
be nominated for one of the 50 movies he
was in this year and he was for the
imitation game before that he actually
played Stephen Hawking in a BBC film
check it out
I really small that we are and
significantly we maybe we can reach your
full understanding of the universe you
were right when you said you felt small
looking up at all that out there
Wow to paraphrase Robert Downey jr. from
Tropic Thunder he went full Hawking it
was kind of funny Cumberbatch nominated
for best actor Eddie Redmayne nominated
for best actor for playing Stephen
Hawking you know what this means
we need a Hawking off you know who else
is nominated from the theory of
everything Felicity Jones you also saw
her this year in the amazing spider-man
2 but way before all this she was in a
TV show called the worst which I'm Ethel
hello could you give me a lift
I'd love to but guys really scoop
Twitter bored I'm not I've been flying
for ages it's really easy when you know
how just ordered to hover
what kind of janky ask low-budget Harry
Potter she was that birdman nominee
edward norton was famous right from the
get-go but fellow nominee and fellow
hulk Mark Ruffalo was in the super sweet
80s acne commercial check it out you can
run but you can't hide you zap one
pimple another one appears you need to
zap three peoples you have fight once
you don't double sad Oh smash acne
I love Julianne Moore and she is
nominated for still Alice
I had forgotten she was the tattletale
doctor who tries to get Harrison Ford
busted in the fugitive check it out what
do you want I want to know how that boy
ended up the surgery look I'm a janitor
I do what I'm told
who changes orders know what you need
what an art Rosamund Pike is nominated
for gone girl but her first movie role
was as a Bond girl playing another Ice
Queen Miranda Frost remember I know what
about you double herself sex Medina
death for breakfast what it's not gonna
work with me oh no you know what I bet
she's not acting and she's just a
terrible lady it was so good of you to
bring your gun to bed with us
Best Actor nominee Michael Keaton was
Batman then Birdman but before that he
starred alongside everyone's second
favorite Belushi in this 1979 sitcom
called working stiffs least and now
we're looking at you
just looking oh man we're only inches
apart hey you'll never forget that guy's
face as long as you live
never I'll always be embedded on the top
of your eyelids right right I could how
could a man you'll never forget my face
no you won't Mike why and that my
friends is how he got the reputation for
the best spit-take in Hollywood Ethan
Hawke is nominated for his performance
in Richard Linklater's beautiful film
boyhood but back in 1985 he starred
alongside River Phoenix in this kid's
adventure movie called explorers take a
look we come in peace
great now try how do we get back to our
ship your skin in a minute he's probably
just translating in his head what kept
what
wow that was 30 years ago or as richard
linklater likes to put it two and a half
movies ago and finally we have Patricia
Arquette who's nominated for boyhood
she's been in a ton of cool things
including true romance one of my
favorite movies but I believe her most
noteworthy performance is her turn in
Nightmare on Elm Street three dream
warriors
you know she may or may not walk out of
there with Oscar gold but she will hold
the distinction of being the only
nominee ever to be almost eaten by a
giant Freddy Krueger headed snake well
that was a nice time what's your
favorite early performance from an Oscar
nominee let us know tell us why in the
comments section below best answer we're
gonna send you screen junkies t-shirt I
want to thank you for watching I'm Holly
with Nick hit me up on Twitter bye bye
and the winner is John Travolta at the
Oscars please welcome the wickedly
talented one and only Adele does E good
one Travolta